- Des vaches dieieieieieieieieié
de cette ferme de Normandie
et des poulets qui sont vendus
dans de nombreux marchés
à tra
agricole diversifiée qui se fait
désormais à fort prix.
BRUNO GUYANT, gérant,
la Ferme du Coudroy
je dirige l'exploitation.
C'est jamais arrivé d'avoir
à subir de telles hausses.
- Augmentation bien sûr
mais aussi de l'azote utilisé
pour fertiliser les ch...
- Un camion d'azote coûtait
5000 euros. Aujourd'hui,
en faut 13 camions par an,
donc c'est csasasal.
L'augmentation, elle est
colossale. Ça déséquilibre
de l'entreprise.
- Ceriririculteur n'a pas
le choix : cette pression se
reflète sur les prix de sa gammn
des pots de yogourt. Le pouleteu
deux hausses cette année.
- C'est une chose qui n'art t tx
une fois par an, et là,
en six mois, on va être obligés
de le faire deux fois,
et ce n'est peut-kikikikikikiki,
au marché de Dieppe, la hausse
des coûts de production se fait
sentir sur les factures
- Forcément, ils comprennent
parce que tout augmente,stststs.
c'est obligé. Pn ne peut pasres.
- Sondage après sondage,
les enjeux liés au coûtnfnfnfnfn
et au pouvoir d'achat sont
la priorité des électeurs
français depuis des mois.
Des préoccupatamamamamamamamamae
début de la guerre en Ukraine.
Prix des aliments, coûts
du carburant : des phénomènes
qui se
dans les paniers au marché
de Dieppe. Ici, le samedi est
l'occasion drérérérérérérérérére
de la semaine, il faut
surveiller les dépenses.
à nos budgetsé. Il y a un petit
peu de privation. Bon, comment
dirais-je? On dépense un peu
plus le weekend, mais sinon,
- Pour contrauauauauausses,
le gouvernement français a
offert un rabais à la pompe.ntnt
promet aussi une prime
aux travailleurs. Une réponse
insuffisante, selon cette femme,
qui évi i i i i i i i i i i i iu
d'Emmanuel Macron auprès
de certains électeurs.
- Je suis désolée de le dire,
très riches. Donc, bien sûr
qu'il va y avoir un impact.
- Dans cette région
où se côtoient terre et mer,
de frontières.
- 7,50 que ça faisait.
- Paquita Classon vend en ville
les poissons et fruits de me
que son mari a pêchés.
Malgré la hausse du carburant,
pour que l'impact sur les prix
soit limité.
PAQUITA CLASSON,
armatrice, bateau "P'tit Roi"
On se dit que s'il y a un peu
de pêche, l l l l l l l loin,
ça nous évite de faire de la
route, donc ça fait moins
pour l'instant, on tient,
maispapapapapapapas combien
de temps. On verra.
- Paquita ne sait pas
des solutions. Elle constatecacé
les difficultés, ses clients
continuent de s'arrêter
de petits plaisirs.- - - - - - a
des gens qui sont contents
de pouvoir se faire plququququqe
Saint-Jacques. Ils le dise
des fois : "Bon, bien, allez, on
se fait plaisir, on en prend."
Radio-Canada, à Diepp